so this is a big day for you the stock
is already down nine percent you haven't
seen it defined like this in 17 years
Wall Street's watching why should they
own Walmart stock well we're here today
and had a nice meeting with our analyst
community to talk about the future of
the company a nice long meeting and what
we're talking about is how we transform
the company Stephanie and we're making
some investments in people and in
technology and what the market reacted
to today was some news that frankly has
been in the market we started this year
to announce some wage investments in
there big numbers we raised our starting
wage rate this year to $9 here in the US
and our stores and clubs and next year
we're going to ten dollars and that's a
big pressure point for us next year on
top of an e-commerce investment but what
we did today was to describe how we're
going to win in the future
now we win by bringing it all together
three years if I'm somebody who invests
in Walmart today why do I want to do
something it's gonna take three years to
get paid to really get a payoff well
next year in particular is where the
pressure point is and then we start to
improve earnings where we go from there
but the bottom line is we've got to get
this company position to serve customers
in the longer term we're building a
technology company within Walmart we're
creating a digital company in addition
to the stores that we have and when the
investments we're making a store level
on top of that it creates some
short-term pressures we're surprised
not entirely but it is interesting to
point out that the $10 wage investment
which next year is 1.5 billion dollars
this year we put a little over a billion
dollars into our stores was public
knowledge and we've already said it so
one question would be was the math in
the in the multiple and I guess Tom will
tell but it was information that was out
there how much of that investment
do you expect to come back to all in
terms of larger centers and at what
point
yeah our strategy is to win with
customers and our clean fast friendly
scores and our us stores have gone from
being 17% favorable or acceptable
February in February of this year to 67%
so the investments we're making our
customers are already seeing the benefit
and by running great stores you can then
set the stage for price investments and
other things as we look forward in the
future to create the Walmart that is at
its best and that combined with digital
things like grocery home shopping and
what we're doing with e-commerce put us
in a position to win next year is the
year when it's the real pressure point
why would I buy your stock today
why wouldn't I wait see how you do in
this improvement plan and buy part of
what we announced today is a twenty
billion dollar share repurchase program
and it's authorized and it's our intent
to invest that in the next couple of
years so we believe in our stock price
and you see it because we're putting our
money where our mouth
so Walmart is a bellwether for the
economy border generally not just in
that sense we around the world as you
look forward into next year where do you
see the growth potential and where do
you see some challenges
yeah what we share today is that we're
really focused on the United States
North America and China in particular so
there's gonna be a lot of growth coming
out of those two markets the investments
that we're making help us be able to
serve customers in a way that we can
take advantage of that growth I think
the US market next year is going to be
at least as good as it is this year your
margins are so small are you going to
reap Thanks
is this the right strategy when you look
at other stores that are saying we want
to be low cost but aspirational and have
higher end products that hasn't been
your mantra do you want to change your
strategy
we are in a people business our
associates do the work and they deserve
this increase and what they're going to
do and already doing is to show that to
our customers and create a better
customer experience in our stores which
ultimately is what matters
so fastened on China and you mentioned
China
we actually have insight into real data
in real time are you seeing consumer
spending pulled up in China or you see
there's there's some pressure there but
there's not a complete tether to what
you read in the news and what you see in
the stock market in China we have super
centers in China we're growing share our
Sam's Clubs in China are doing great and
we bought the rest of an e-commerce
business based in Shanghai earlier this
year so now we've set the stage in China
as we have here in the US the wind about
creating a seamless shopping experience
for customers they're going to be able
to order on their mobile device have a
deliverer pick it up in a store
depending on the circumstance in the
market so that they can save time as
well as money and that's going to happen
in China as well as happening so to be
clear your stock drop today would you
attribute that to your cost structure
and the changes you're making in the
company or we also look to Walmart to
understand the US consumer is the u.s.
consumer shopping last hurting more I
think this is more about the company
than it is the market and it's a
question of short-term versus long-term
and what we're saying is we believe in
this business for the long
we're gonna do what's necessary to put
Walmart in a position to win we've got
some great assets we have a terrific
supply chain we've got all these
distribution points in our stores and
when you put those together with the
digital capabilities that we're building
we have a winning strategy the
alternative would be to not invest just
keep running the business the way we've
been running it and then eventually
years ahead of time it's all marked so
big and has some momentum gonna take
forever for the business to be in
jeopardy literally forever but now she
grabbed the steering wheel and you do
what's necessary to position for the
customer we set ourselves up for a
stronger position in
yes so I mean without using a word
leveraging stores I mean we built that
distribution center several of them
opened this year which was another
investment to create each fulfillment
and as we put that together with our
other distribution centers in our stores
we can allow a customer to order online
and have it over to their house if it's
not a food item order online pick it up
in a store on the parking lot over time
we got a great test going on here in
this country as we have that in the UK
for a few years where you can pick it up
in the parking lot or not go in the
store or you can choose to go in the
store it's really about blending the
channels together the customer won't
have to think about how do I order it or
choose to buy it it's just there where
everywhere or how do I want to pick it
up or take delivery of it it will be
able to serve them in multiple ways you
need to rebrand yourself for us to
really think of you as a technology
company and have a big marketing spend
because when I think where's my one-stop
shop online I default to Amazon not
because I prefer it to Walmart's just
partially we had to put all the
capabilities in place so we had to build
the digital platform we had to create
the fulfillment centers we had to earn
that we're now getting closer to that
point we've now got the third most
visited mobile app and retail in the
country and we've been known for a long
time for price and assortment now we
just have to deliver that in a different
way so we probably will make some
investment to communicate that message
and we've already started to do a little
bit
but we wanted to make sure we had the
right customer experience in place
before we started telling everybody
about it and it's like we said with the
analysts today as it relates to our
investment of people in our stores and
clean up your house before you invite
people over and that's what we've done
so let's talk specifically I think what
I read at least on Bloomberg News was
that the projections for profits next
year was six to twelve percent range
down to pool which is if you took out
your investments your e-commerce and
your people
seventy five percent of next year's
investment that's on top of the costs we
have in our business is related to
people so it's about 1.5 billion dollars
as our associates enjoy an increase to
ten dollars as a minimum starting wage
rate and we've added department managers
and done some other things to invest in
people that adds up to 75 percent of the
pressure the rest of it is in e-commerce
and some of it is in a price investment
that we intend to make next year do you
know who your customer is we're seeing
you make a bigger push into organic
groceries try to go for a more diverse
product line when your consumer is
looking for the lowest cost items its
Walmart employees many oh don't ask
don't pigeonhole our customers I showed
a chart today and we we had the US by
income level and our customer by income
level and when you get a chance go back
and look at it the United States I don't
know
you live here not everybody lives in New
York City if people know and love
Walmart and we've got customers from all
income levels now will they like the
e-commerce investment yes will they like
the services will building for them yes
well shareholders more income customers
might like it but you need shareholders
to like it this week tomorrow not just
this week we need shareholders to like
it over time and if you don't win with
customers and associates our employees
you don't win with shareholders so for
me this is really clear I am excited and
committed to what we're doing as you
would guess and so is our management
team and our associates are buying in
we're absolutely doing the right thing
it's just going to take a bit of time